una profunda crisis económica es una de
las múltiples consecuencias de la retoma
del poder por parte de los talibanes en
afganistán
todos los precios han subido y no
podemos comprar nada y la gente tiene
serios problemas económicos porque los
bancos han cerrado y las condiciones del
mercado no son buenas no hay
oportunidades de trabajo y nadie puede
permitirse comprar nada la agencia de
calificación fitch estima que la
economía afgana podría caer casi un 10%
este año fiscal y 5.2 por ciento el
siguiente y en este contexto de bloqueo
económico además agravado por las
sequías los afganos esperan para conocer
lo que será su nuevo gobierno uno del
que un portavoz talibán ya dio adelantos
sin lugar a dudas era un gobierno
islámico la gente ha hecho grandes
sacrificios por el establecimiento de un
gobierno islámico sin embargo se pensara
adecuadamente actualmente estamos
teniendo discusiones y hemos tenido
consultas ojala el liderazgo llegue a
una buena conclusión
se espera que el líder supremo de los
talibanes jaiba to la juntada tenga el
poder final sobre un nuevo consejo de
gobierno y aunque los talibanes prometen
ser más moderados eeuu y la unión
europea desconfían y se enfocan en poder
evacuar a más personas de ese país
y no vamos a reconocer a los talibanes
pero vemos la necesidad de poder tener
un contacto directo de lo contrario no
podemos enviar mensajes y no podemos
escuchar la respuesta uno fue su enfoque
con respecto al aeropuerto durante la
evacuación ahora estamos en un espacio
diferente podremos ver un paso seguro
para salir de afganistán esa sería la
primera prueba bastante importante y
necesitamos poder discutir eso
hasta el gobierno de qatar avanza en
diálogos con los talibanes y trabaja de
la mano de turquía con miras a la
reapertura del aeropuerto de kabul